У Белхатуві на півдні Польщі мешкає близько 50 тисяч людей.
Багато хто переїхав сюди в 70-х роках - через робочі місця,
які тоді були створені на електростанції та буровугільній шахті.
Сьогодні ці два підприємства належать
"Польській енергетичній групі" - скорочено PGE.
Ця електростанція позаду мене викидає найбільше
парникових газів у всьому Європейському Союзі.
Це місце спричиняє понад 30 мільйонів тонн вуглекислого газу.
Це символ прив'язаності Польщі до вугілля.
30 мільйонів тонн шкідливого для довкілля вуглекислого газу
щороку лише тут, у Белхатуві. Це більше, ніж викидається
в атмосферу в цілій Ірландії чи Словаччині.
"Грінпіс" хоче покласти цьому край.
Активісти роками протестують тут проти забруднення довкілля.
Ми повинні відмовитися від вугілля до 2030 року,
якщо ми дійсно хочемо реалізувати Паризьку угоду.
Ми бачимо, що зараз відбувається останніми роками.
Фактично, уряд проспав ці роки в питанні енергетичної трансформації.
Найбільша в Європі електростанція, що працює на бурому вугіллі,
забезпечує близько п'ятої частини потреб Польщі в електроенергії.
Оператор PGE оголосив, що крок за кроком згортатиме
діяльність електростанції між 2030 і 2036 роками
в рамках проголошеної у Польщі мети поступово
відмовитися від вугілля.
Поки що Польща не дотримується кліматичної політики ЄС.
Уряд запровадив спеціальні правила та продовжує субсидувати
свої вугільні електростанції.
Польська енергетична група відмовляється коментувати
цю ситуацію на камери. Відвідин електростанції PGE
також уникає. Ймовірно, через шкідливий вплив на довкілля
та наслідки цього для місцевих жителів.
Те, що ми спостерігаємо в районі електростанції, -
це невидимий ворог, який фактично вкорочує життя людям,
які там живуть. Хоча сам пил може поширюватися
на багато кілометрів. Він вкорочує життя людей
і збільшує кількість інфарктів та інсультів.
Попри шкоду для здоров'я, більшість мешканців Белхатува
все ще проти закриття вугільної електростанції.
Нам не подобається, що закривають шахту.
Тут багато робочих місць.
Економічна ситуація може погіршитися.
Без шахти Белхатув був би маленьким селом
з 2000 мешканців.
Погано, коли шахту закриють. Що буде з людьми, які сюди переїхали?
Я боюся, що нема плану, що буде з містом далі.
Тут живе один із перших працівників шахти - Леон Войновський.
Вугільна промисловість є невід'ємною частиною його життя.
Нині чоловік на пенсії. Він охоче розповідає
про свою колишню роботу.
Тоді зібралася велика група молодих інженерів з усієї Польщі.
Вони були сповнені ентузіазму щодо цього проєкту.
Свою пристрасть до вуглевидобування
чоловік зберіг і донині. Каже, це були найкращі часи його життя.
До цього належать також різні шахтарські звичаї,
як, приміром, місцеві фестивалі пива.
Мені сумно, що цей звичай зникне,
коли закінчиться видобуток вугілля.
Мешканці Белхатува поки що не мають конкретних уявлень,
що з ними буде далі, після закриття шахти.
Одне нове велике підприємство не зможе замінити
вугільну промисловість.
До того ж розвиток нового бізнесу потребує грошей.
Щоб трансформація була успішною, необхідне бажання
і співпраця усіх сторін: приватного сектору, влади,
громадських організацій тощо.
Це зараз обговорюється на багатьох семінарах.
Ми працюємо з молоддю, з бізнесменами, з чиновниками,
з громадськими організаціями. Що для них важливо -
це краще транспортне сполучення, кращий зв'язок,
екологія, довкілля, а також соціальна згуртованість.
Проблема теж у тому, що десятиліттями робота
у вугільній промисловості оплачувалась настільки добре,
що багато сімей у Белхатуві могли дозволити собі
кілька автомобілів. Громадський транспорт майже
не використовувався і тому він мало розвинений.
Якщо нові компанії захочуть переїхати до Белхатува,
це має змінитися.
Якщо буде дуже добре транспортне сполучення,
сюди прийдуть інвестори, які захочуть розмістити тут свої заводи.
Без комунікації та логістики ми не залучимо до роботи
нових людей із вузькоспеціалізованих галузей,
IT, програмістів та інших.
Хоча працівники вугільної електростанції в Белхатуві
підтримують свою вугільну промисловість,
вони аж ніяк не прив'язані до неї з ідеологічних причин.
На багатьох дахах їхніх будинків - сонячні панелі.
Бізнес із сонячною енергією процвітає - не в останню чергу
завдяки державним субсидіям.
Маріуш, який продає сонячні системи, щороку подвоює свої продажі.
У нас в регіоні майже кожен інсталював таку систему.
Кожен вважає, що для них це економічно вигідно.
Белхатув досі живе за рахунок найбільшої та найбруднішої
вугільної електростанції в Європі.
Брюссель готовий допомогти, щоб і тут люди перейшли
на кліматичну політику ЄС.